week 11 done over finito and the
Chargers are done over and finito they
fell in Mexico City last night to the
Kansas City Chiefs 24 to 17 Chris Sims
I'm going to resist making it all about
me and being right on my best bets two
and one this week
I trusted the Chiefs to cover it looked
like it was going to be a blowout it was
24 to 9 I got to give the Chargers
credit for making it interesting the
cheese were ready to run away with it it
ended up being a pretty exciting finish
well definitely I mean gosh 24 to 9 but
it should have been 21 nothing chargers
to start the game I mean it was the game
was served up on a silver platter for
them you know they're driving down they
missed field goals they're driving down
they throw an interception you know they
get an interception from Patrick mahomes
I mean they had so many opportunities to
control the game I mean it was
unbelievable that we went in at halftime
and it was a 10 to 9 Kansas City
advantage when Patrick Herrmann the Hama
Homs had done nothing they had barely
been on the field they really couldn't
create any offense and that's really
where you knew that the Chargers were in
trouble I mean how many times have we
said this over the last few weeks Mike
where you know you look at a team when
they had all these opportunities to
really put themselves in the position of
power and kind of controlled the flow of
the game and they blew those
opportunities and they let Kansas City
hang around and then Kansas City kind of
found their mojo there early in the
third quarter and you're right at least
they fought back and had a chance to
pull it out in the end nonetheless yeah
and look Patrick mahomes in the first
half was sluggish the guy still is I
don't want to say rusty but he hasn't
played a lot of football in the last
month he had the game last week at
Tennessee and you pointed out there were
some throws that that weren't
characteristic Patrick mahomes throws
then he mentioned after the game why he
wasn't as sharp early on as he needed to
be let's listen to what my home say
because it fits with one of the themes
that we have as to how you defend the
Chiefs in this this second season of
mahomes as the starter here he is from
last night
I think the biggest thing as office the
first half is me being a little too over
aggressive there was times where you saw
the second half I kind of just took the
check downs I hit the running backs out
of the backfield when I had those early
in the game and I so just kind of going
back and reevaluate myself during the
game during halftime and realizing that
if they're gonna get depth and they're
gonna kind of take away our shots that
if we're not to just kind of take what's
there and then whenever we get the
opportunities like we had with Kelsey in
the red zone there you take advantage of
those see Chris I'm confused why I took
him a full half of football to figure
this out we've known all along that
that's how teams are gonna defend them
this year he said it himself right he
wants to have the spectacular plays he
wants to throw the ball down the field
especially at the 70 342 foot elevation
of Mexico City where the ball goes even
farther so if they're trying to take
that away from you you don't force it
you don't wait for it to pop you take
what's available and I'm glad he finally
figured it out but he should have
figured it out a lot sooner than at
halftime
well this is a fundamental problem with
the Kansas City Chiefs I mean we've seen
that when you want to beat the Kansas
City Chiefs other than maybe the New
England Patriots who have the corners to
get up in their face and play bump and
run and do things like that this is
exactly what the Chargers did to them
late last year and when they beat them
in Kansas City on that what was that a
Saturday night game or a Thursday night
game hours day Thursday night game this
is exactly the same game plan now what
gives me hope is last year Kansas City
just continued to run deep guys down the
field and thinking like Oh something was
going to change let me just keep knockin
my head against the wall and see if
there's something something changes that
way but it didn't and that's what I was
afraid of Lassa that's where I got to
give Eric be enemy and Andy read a lot
of credit that they did come out in the
second half and said okay you know no
Tyree kill they are dropping way down
the field they are not gonna let us
throw our normal deep you know
aggressive pass plays and they did calm
or underneath things to gliese sustain
some drives and get some mojo going that
way and that's that was big to me it
really was it was really to me the key
to the football game because I didn't
know if Kansas City
and II read historically and Eric the
enemy could look at oh let's run the
ball if they're gonna drop back and
let's throw the ball short you know
traditionally they've kind of been
stubborn that way yeah I agree with you
completely and you mentioned the failure
of the Chargers to score points when
they had an opportunity with a team like
the Chiefs when you have a chance to put
them on the mat you have to because you
know eventually they are going Chris to
score their points and the Chargers
should have been leading at the first
half they should have been leading big
they shouldn't have been losing at
halftime and the Chiefs pulled away but
I have to give the Chargers credit for
making it interesting the only problem
is it set the stage for yet another
Philip Rivers failure and Chris all
seven losses this year for the Chargers
have been by seven points or fewer this
gets back to something we've mentioned
time and again close games last year it
went their way more often than not they
were twelve and four this year it's not
going their way in the close games
they're four and seven and seven is the
magic number in a variety of ways
because Philip Rivers now has seven
interceptions the last two weeks
including the throw that ended the game
yeah just not great football by him has
you know some of them some of it been a
little unlucky yeah sure I mean that one
right there it gets hit B you know if
you're watching on TV gets hit be hot
from behind as he's throwing the
football put that one there the one down
the middle of the honey badger horrible
I mean there's no other way you could
say it and especially in a moment of the
game where Kansas City's offense had
done nothing and all of a sudden you're
gonna give them basically a five yard
touchdown drive to get them going but
you know I think the big thing is Philip
Rivers still can make a lot of big-time
plays I do think at times though he's
just over aggressive too freewheeling
that way and also not realistic in the
go okay I'm what does he 38 39 years old
my arms not the same as it once was it
was never a awesome unbelievable arm and
certainly not now and I think he thinks
he's gonna get away with some throws
that you know I've you know obviously
he's not gonna get away with how do you
coach that out of him at this stage of
his career in life yeah that's a tough
one Mike I don't know if you can I mean
it's it's this is something that's
really going to
have to be on him to kind of have that
trigger in his brain to wear when he
sees a tight window 20 25 yards down the
field he's got a almost second-guess
himself or put a little governor in his
brain to go you know what I've seen this
before let me just throw it underneath
and I'll live to play another day and
maybe I get another opportunity to throw
that ball down there either way but you
know because of lack of arm strength -
he has to throw balls way before the
picture kind of presents itself at times
I mean he's got great anticipation and
all those things he always has that's
really been a great strength of his game
but you know when you're when you don't
have a fastball that you know can drive
the ball in there all the time that
means you have to make some dice she
throws sometimes in throw balls where oh
the guy's not in the window yet but I
got to throw it right now because that's
the only way excuse me we're gonna get
it completed and those are the things
he's kind of struggling with especially
the last two weeks Rivers himself was
asked after the game why he is currently
throwing so many interceptions here's
what he had to say
let's football game oh yeah you know if
you just pick and choose and never throw
them ever I choose to throw zero so
certainly don't don't want to throw them
but certainly I know it's hurting us
right now you know that explanation
falls into the stuff happens category
and I don't buy that because and I did
this last hour on radio Chris I'm sure
you weren't listening because you pay no
attention to me when you're not actually
having to talk to me but plenty of other
quarterbacks have much better touchdown
to interception ratio right now then
Philip Rivers who's at 15 touchdowns and
14 interceptions you've got some guys
with stunning numbers here Kirk Cousins
21 and 3
you've got Russell Wilson still at 23
and - you've got dak Prescott at 21 and
9 Patrick mahomes 19 and 2 guys are
taking care of the ball guys and making
good decisions and not throwing the ball
into traffic and just hoping for the
best and I feel like with with Phillip
Rivers just as you said there's too many
of these occasions where he just kind of
throws it up on a wing and a prayer and
hopes for the best yeah well last year
like you you opened up the show he kind
of limited those type of things and of
course they were twelve and four
football team but all those years before
that you know this has kind of been a
more of a reoccurring theme than he or
any Chargers fan was like you know over
the last four or five years now I liked
pertaining to this year uh you know I
got to give them like the benefit of the
the matter as far as the o-line
certainly is not great so that's gonna
cause some issues and that caused
probably two interceptions last night
during the game the other thing is the
run game especially early this year had
you know no juice at all that's really
just come along here lately so with
those two things alone it is a lot on
Phillip Rivers and he does have to push
the envelope if they want to win
football games and move the ball
offensively and they have weapons and
they've kind of been playing in that
style but yeah for a guy that's got as
much you know experience as he does it's
it's a few too many stakes mistakes and
it's it's concerning in this moment and
it's been some big mistake some big
moments not only these these two games
but you know some other games it's
reared its ugly head early in the year
as well let's play that last
interception again because it looks like
yeah he was trying to thread the needle
and drop it in over the defender he knew
that if that was there yes he just
flat-out misses and and this isn't the
throw it up and hope for the best this
is the here's my guy I'm gonna drop it
in you can even see the way he throws it
it's kind of like that you know trying
to throw something into a trash can like
I know exactly what I need to do I'm
just gonna I'm gonna flip it in there
and it just missed it Chris yeah just
missed it look at that it's just like
yeah I'm gonna drop it in no I'm not and
man I tell you I'm a Chargers fan you
know we criticize plenty of quarterbacks
on this show Phillip Rivers has escaped
if I'm a Chargers fan I'm done I'm done
and we got to find somebody else and
they're I don't know what other options
are gonna be available next year but Cam
Newton may be available Tom Brady may be
available rookies in the draft may be
available not that you know I don't I'm
not saying they should go after Brady
but the point that I've been making
about the charges over and over again if
they're gonna compete with the Rams yes
they have to be thinking about substance
sorry and style yeah and you know and we
need guys that are gonna cause people to
separate with their money and decide to
show up and watch these players play and
Philip Rivers
I don't know after this year is going to
inspire anybody in LA to show up and
watch the Chargers play well I think
that point is very real right now I mean
the Rams are running away with the the
attention in LA and have all the star
power of course with Jalen Ramsey and
Aaron Donald and Jared Goff and Todd
Gurley they've kind of seemed to have
found their niche within the city and
yes the Chargers have not and this
certainly is not going to go a long way
either as you know and again he's a
legend of the sport Phillip Rivers he
really is but for that new fan that's
let's say 12 and younger 15 and younger
they might not know a lot about Phillip
Rivers or care they want somebody in
there or players in there that you know
they can gravitate towards now and I
think that's that's the problem the
Chargers are gonna have to think about
whether it's this year or next year but
they're certainly getting towards you
know that part of the career where
Phillip Rivers and I know he made some
comments last week talking about it's a
year at a time and I think he's very
realistic and knowing that you know this
is this is coming down to the last year
or two for him as well yeah he said he's
gonna regroup after the season he wants
to stay with the Chargers his contract
expires I just think the Chargers have
to make that dispassionate emotionless
decision that teams make all the time
about every player on the roster at one
point or another is it time to move on
and I think it's time for the Chargers
to move on from Phillip Rivers I hate to
say that but that's our job to recognize
the situation and say what needs to be
said we don't mind being in those kind
of football games you know I felt like
you know we've been challenged a lot
this season you know we played a lot of
good football teams a lot of
quarterbacks you know we've been in that
situation you know maybe four or five
times this year and so I think our
defense is starting to get confidence
you know I think we're starting to want
to be in that situation you know so we
could make a play and we could get the
ball back to office Tyra Matthew Chiefs
safety one of the reasons why the
defense is different this year it's hard
to know how much better the Chiefs
defense really is because there have
been moments where it hasn't been great
but then there are moments where it
steps up like last night with the four
interceptions Matthew had one he had no
one right in his hands Chris is this
defense good enough at this point I mean
the team has lost four games this year
they they have a lot of work to do and
they need some help to get back in
position to even have a bye week in the
postseason do you think that once the
playoffs are all around this is a
defense that can help them win more
games and they won last year well III do
I don't know I do think it's more
conducive to playoff football now you
know ever since that Houston Texans
deshaun Watson game you know they have
been better and I know you've heard me
say this a lot right you know even in
their loss to the Tennessee Titans man I
mean yes Derek Henry he ran all over
them I get that he broke two big rubber
you know one really big run where they
kind of messed up the run fit but their
pass defense has been a pain in the butt
you know they gave Kirk Cousins some
paint you know a tough time when he came
to town and didn't let Dalvin cook do
all that much you know last night we're
a pain in the butt from Phillip Rivers
we saw what they did to the Denver
Broncos in Denver and really if it
wasn't Aaron Rodgers you'd heard me say
this too that the Green Bay Packers were
in strugglers ville - I mean just if you
know think about some of the highlight
throws we throw saw from that game that
night from Aaron Rodgers that helped
move the ball I mean he was really maybe
him and mahomes were the only two guys
in the league that could have completed
some of those passes so I am encouraged
with what they see they're not gonna be
ever in the top 15 or anything like that
they don't have enough difference-makers
and things like that but two things they
have been more aggressive they disguise
more and they've been putting more big
people on the line of scrimmage to at
least slow down the run now it didn't
work against the Tennessee Titans but
all the other games they have slowed
down the run to where its formidable on
the defensive side
and the schedule isn't quite formidable
but it's not easy down the stretch for
the Chiefs they have the Raiders after
the by Oakland comes to town then it's
at New England on the Sunday of week 14
that is not going to be an easy game the
broncos visit Arrowhead Stadium after
that the Broncos have a very good
defense and they are capable of keeping
a game close yeah they were horrible on
that Thursday night the night that my
homes got injured but the Broncos are
not an easy out as the Vikings learned
on Sunday then it's at the Bears at
Chicago in December I don't care who the
quarterback for the Bears is at the time
it's not gonna be an easy game for
Kansas City and then they wrap with a
visit from the Chargers who beat them in
Kansas City last year and as we saw last
night are still capable of playing them
tough so that this is not five straight
wins waiting for the Chiefs down the
stretch oh that this could this could
get interesting and and look I think
they'll make the playoffs to give that
defense a chance to thrive in January
but they may not have ideal playoff
positioning and given their struggles at
home this year maybe it's good that
they'd be the five seed with 62 not have
to play a home game well they would
probably argue on that but I hear what
you're saying and they have not defended
the you know Arrowhead Stadium the way
we're accustomed to seeing now the thing
that jumps out to me you know you talked
about these last five games Raiders
Patriots Broncos Bears Chargers none of
them are great offenses none of them so
that's a good thing now they got to play
some tough defenses and their offense is
certainly gonna have to play better than
it did last night I think that's the one
the one big thing but you know what's
scary about the Chiefs is again just
think about the first half it's a
miracle that they went in ten to nine I
mean they were out game 312 yards two to
a hundred and nine the Chargers had the
ball for 20 something minutes the Chiefs
had it for nine minutes now they were
fortunate that Phillip Rivers threw a
bad interception backed up in his own
area that gave them a cheap touchdown
and a six yard touchdown drive but yes
that kind of reared its ugly head last
night to where I feel like they played a
little bit of slow death football in the
first half and in the
in half they at least tried to play
man-to-man and get in their face a
little bit more than we saw in the first
half of the game yeah and you know they
have the talent on the defensive side of
the ball and they've got the players who
can step up at key moments whether it's
Tyrann Mathieu or a Frank Clark and I
think that's the other element to this -
sure set aside the scheme you set aside
whether or not you're gonna Blitzer what
you when you have players that you know
will when the game is on the line when
the season is on the line they will find
that higher level of performance
whatever the context may be whatever the
specific plate design may be they're
gonna make a play it helps to have guys
like that and they really didn't have
that last year and they have that this
year I think that may help make a
difference I I agree to get to the post
yeah agree with that I do in Frank Clark
you know he's enough to start earning
that money I mean he popped a little
last night Chris Jones we know he's
capable of doing that honey badger we
saw last night so you're right there are
some playmakers and I just think they're
gonna be a pain in the butt but never a
great defense
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports